hi Bill Nye this is Sam pastor and my
question for you is as an art student
myself do I have to choose between art
and science for our next generations to
thrive or can art in science coexist
please let me know thanks Sam
Sam Sann art and science have to coexist
they're both human endeavors
however just keep in mind you know I'm
the Science Guy in like this that
science this process that humans have
developed seems to be to my way of
thinking the best idea we've had best
idea we've had about how to know nature
how to know our place in in the world in
the cosmos but without art we would
hardly be people art is created by
people and it inspires each of us it's
the way we send messages it's the way we
we motivate each other or keep each
other from doing something it's an art
is part of us we don't want art or
science we want both with that said a
little commentary about our current
controversy in education in the United
States everybody goes on and on with
this acronym stem stem stem stem stem
stem science technology engineering and
math and this is a fine acronym it talks
about or it was a develop was created to
address what was a clear need here in
the United States after people landed on
the moon investment in basic research
was curtailed except in the military
spending and so we stopped the United
States stopped doing as much basic
research as it had been doing and so to
reinvigorate this scuse me people
created this acronym and there's all
these science technology engineering and
math programs in school it's good that's
good now people talk about steam science
technology engineering art and math well
good yes then I've heard steamed
science technology engineering art math
and design okay
pretty soon the acronyms gonna have all
the letters that we would call school to
school you go to school and you've got
to have math you've got to have language
arts English in my case and in the
United States where English is the
primary language you got to have history
you got to have I'd like us to have
civics about the US Constitution and the
behavior and the way the government is
creating and we got to have art
you got to have science yes we got to
have all that but this tacking stuff on
this acronym that became so popular stem
is it's okay but everybody let's not
forget we got to do everything you kids
not one or the other please it's not one
or the other
learn the process of science you don't
have to become a scientist full-time or
an engineer full-time and for those who
love science and engineering I hope you
pursue some art and learn some art for
crying out and - how to create art
yourself and appreciate it that's what
makes us people go for it